dans sa petite maison du nord de
Winnipeg
avec sa fille Willow qui fait très bien
tout son troisième anniversaire
mais derrière c'est sourire se cachent
une profonde colère après la mort
violente de Morgan heres la mère de
Cambria
la vie de cambriya n'a pas été facile
entre famille d'accueil et foyer pour
jeunes elle qui a été séparée de sa mère
lorsqu'elle n'avait que 6 ans my firsty
school c'est pour tous sont un lointain
souvenir de ces quelques années de vie
familiale heureuse
après avoir perdu la garde de ses
enfants la mère de Cambria assombri elle
a perdu sa maison et s'est retrouvé à la
rue où ses problèmes de toxicomanie et
de santé mentale se sont aggravés
pendant plus de 10 ans a vécu dans la
rue elle a été vue pour la dernière fois
au mois de mai
nous l'avons cherché ici mais nous ne
l'avons pas trouvé raconte qu'un
brouilla
[Musique]
depuis son adolescence en 2014 elle
manifestait après la mort de Tina
fontaine en promettant de ne pas être la
prochaine
c'est finalement le nom de sa mère qui
s'est ajouté à la triste des victimes
domicides l'an dernier est près de 20%
des victimes de meurtres à Winnipeg
étaient des femmes autochtones quatre
d'entre elles auraient été tuées par le
même homme
trois mères de famille et une femme non
identifiée qui ont été tués le printemps
dernier en l'espace de deux mois en
décembre la police de Winnipeg a arrêté
leur meurtrier présumé un homme qui
avait des antécédents de violences
conjugales et qui maintenant en attente
d'un procès
selon la police le présumé tueur en
série aurait trouvé ses victimes dans
des refuges pour itinérant avant de les
ramener chez lui
c'est ici que ma mère avait un lit avant
d'être assassiné di Cambria c'est aussi
là qu'elle aurait rencontré son présumé
meurtrier
[Musique]
la vie dans les refuges que
fréquentaient Morgan iris était
difficile ces endroits conçus pour être
des abrits temporaires de dernier
recours devient trop souvent des
solutions permanentes pour les plus
vulnérables une situation que déplore
cette directrice générale de refuge
Jasper qu'on est capable de faire la
sécurité pour des personnes qui se
rendent ici chaque soir mais la sécurité
absolue devient ainsi son oeuvre propre
logement les refuges sont pas la
solution
le système a laissé tomber ma mère des
blocs
[Musique]
de chercher la dépouille de Morgan Harry
elle se trouverait dans un dépotoir mais
les fouilles se rétro coûteuses et trous
dangereuses et
surjet
ramener sa mère à la maison devient une
mission
la jeune femme livre plaidoyer après
plaidoyer et se rend même à Ottawa pour
directement interpeller le gouvernement
Trudeau
winnipexandre
aide la famille dans ses démarches
ce sont des conversations violentes que
nous ne devrions pas avoir dit-elle
la pression de la communauté le
gouvernement Trudeau a accepté de
financer une étude pour déterminer si
les fouilles seraient possible trop peu
trop tard selon les agazanas
nous amène au dépotoires du chemin
briggy à une vingtaine de kilomètres au
sud de
winnipegers
à la clôture pour rappeler toutes ces
femmes qui ont disparu sans jamais avoir
été retrouvés et près du grillage ce
signe nous ne sommes pas des déchets
pour maintenir la pression sur les
autorités un campement a été établi
devant la décharge
sur place les campeurs se relève jour et
nuit depuis des semaines
depuis le tout début
ne sait pas si le corps de sa mère est
ici ou dans une autre décharge et sans
réponse les questions se bousculent dans
la tête de la jeune femme
combien d'autres femmes sont enterrées
ici se demande-t-elle
[Musique]
loin de la décharge du chemin bready
dans les rues de Winnipeg les affiches
de femmes disparues continuent de se
multiplier signe que les drames humains
font partie du quotidien que cette crise
ne semble pas avoir de faim
[Musique]